- [Pawan] Time, good evening, everyone.
- [Audience] Good evening.
- [Pawan] Cool, thank you
for joining this session.
My name is Pawan.
I'm one of the principal
serverless specialists.
And here, we're going to talk about,
you know, it's a code talk
about the observability mystery
using Step Functions.
And I'm joined here by my colleague.
Diego, if you wanna introduce yourself?
- [Diego] Yeah, my name is Diego.
I'm a principal engineer on
the AWS Step Functions team.
Been working with Step
Functions for a few years,
and I'm very happy to be here with Pawan
to talk about Step Functions
and that tricky thing just to understand
what's going on with my execution
and where should I look at, mostly,
and also talk about the new
metrics that we just launched.
- [Pawan] Amazing.
How many of you are using Step Functions
in production today?
Just raise, show of hands.
Okay, how many of you have not
used Step Functions at all?
Okay, cool, nice.
So yeah, in terms of the
agenda, what it looks like,
so we're going to start
with like building something
on Step Functions, so we
will see like, you know,
how do you start off.
And then we're going to
slightly increase the level
or the complexity, like, you know,
we'll show about some
of the observability,
how do you actually debug it,
talks about the important concepts
that you would probably
want to keep in mind
while building these Step
Functions in production.
So with that, we'll get started.
So we have four demos.
So the first one.
So this use case is around building
or analyzing the wind speed data.
So for this particular
demo, we are actually going
to use one of the open-source dataset
for which it actually shows
what are the wind speed metrics
is across the globe for
each of the station.
So let me quickly show the dataset.
So this is the dataset
that we're going to use.
And as you see, it includes, you know,
all of these parameters in here,
like, you know, the mean
temperature, dew point, sea level,
and various other things.
What we're interested is into looking
at the wind speed data.
The nice thing is it actually gives you
this single line of command
where you can actually
copy this dataset into an S3 bucket.
In terms of what it looks
like in the S3 bucket,
let's open that up.
So the dataset itself
is partitioned by year
and then it's also partitioned
further into like, you know,
the station ID.
So you can see that, you
know, it includes data
all the way from 1929
and goes up to like 2024, '25.
And if I opening one of
these, you know, buckets,
sorted into Objects, like you can see
these are the different station IDs,
and the data inside that
looks something like this.
So let me zoom this up a bit
so you can see that it has the station ID
and then the date parameter,
the latitude, longitude,
where exactly the station is.
And we're interested in
looking at these parameters.
In terms of the end product,
what it actually looks like is, you know,
we have this particular dashboard
which actually shows the mean wind speed
across all of these different, you know,
the stations across the globe.
And if I click on one of these points,
it's actually going to show where exactly
it is also located.
So let me...
Let's try that again.
So if I click on one of these points,
it's going to show that, you know,
this is located over here.
And then also if I mouse over,
it shows what does that mean,
average wind speed in
that location as well.
Cool, so with that in mind,
let's go ahead and build this.
You know, let's see how do you
actually build this workflow.
So Step Functions, go to
the Step Functions Console.
Let's create a state machine.
Let's give it a name
called windspeed-analysis.
For this type, I'm going to
choose the Standard workflow.
Now, for those who have actually
not used the Step Functions before,
so for you to get started,
the Step Function Console
actually gives you a very nice way
to get started, right?
Under the hood, it actually uses something
called as the Amazon State Language.
So if you're new to it, like,
probably it might be a
bit of a learning curve.
So the console actually
gives you a great place
to get started with.
So the first thing that
you would do is drag
and drop the Map state here.
Let's give it a name for this.
Let's call it as DMap.
And since we're working with
the distributed map here,
so what is distributed map?
So distributed map is ideal for scenarios
where you want to
process large-scale data,
like things of, think in
the order of like millions
of objects that, perhaps, are there in S3,
and then you want to like,
you know, process them.
So the distributed map
can really scale massively
and then help in processing this data.
The dataset that you
saw, the wind speed data,
just to give you an
idea, we have about close
to 600,000 objects in the S3 bucket,
close to about 70 odd, 70GB worth of data.
So let's go ahead and
click the Processing mode.
So there are two modes here.
So either it can be like
Inline or Distributed.
So I'm going to choose Distributed.
And then you can pass in
the, you know, the source.
So either it can be passed in as an input,
that's basically the state
input that you see here,
or in our case, we're going to use S3.
And then I have this dropdown
where I can choose, like,
you know, which particular item source
that I'm going to use.
So this is really, you know,
this list has actually grown recently.
So we introduced the Parquet format,
the support for Athena
data manifest as well.
So in our case, I'm just going
to choose the S3 object list,
and I'm going to point it to the bucket
where the data resides.
So let's choose the bucket.
And then the next configuration
that I want to do is like,
you know, because the way
how this processing works
is it'll pick up one object at a time,
and that's probably may
not be very efficient.
You know, it's recommended
that you would enable the batching
and then, you know, you can say how,
what's the batch size that you want
to take these objects
together and process them.
So for this use case,
let's give it as 500,
500 objects at a time.
You could either batch it by the number
or you can batch it by the
maximum bytes per batch.
The next is the concurrency limit.
This is a powerful feature
of the distributed map.
So this basically tells,
you know, this is basically
where it actually, the scale comes in,
the scale of processing comes into play.
So you can set the
concurrency limit as thousand
as a default, but it can actually
go all the way to 10,000.
So think of, you know, your child workflow
scaling concurrently 10,000
times like in a prompt,
you know, in terms of
the concurrency size.
So I'll leave it as 1,000,
and then I can choose whether I want
to use the Standard
execution or the Express.
So leave it as default.
In terms of the Additional parameters,
I'm just going to set the
Tolerated failure threshold.
So this is in case if my execution
fails for whatever reason
and that threshold crosses 5%,
then I want to deem it as the
entire workflow to be failed.
And finally, the last step is for the,
in terms of configuring
the distributed map,
I'm just going to say where
should this particular
processing output the data into.
So I'm going to provide the
S3 bucket for that as well.
So let me choose
the bucket.
And then I'm going to
prefix it with as demo.
So that's in terms of the distributed map.
Now, let's me configure,
like, this is where,
basically, I need to say, okay,
what should happen inside
the distributed map.
So this is where my business
logic comes into play.
So in case of this wind
speed, like, you know,
it's going to process that
wind speed dataset, right?
So my Lambda function, which
is already pre-created,
what it actually does
is it goes into these
individual date object, and
then looks up all the data,
and then calculates
the mean average speed.
It's a very simple Lambda function.
So I'm going to try to choose the analysis
Lambda function here.
And then I'm going to also drag
and drop another Lambda function.
So think of this workflow
as like a map reducer,
like, you know, the first Lambda function
does the map processing,
so I'm going to call it
as analysis function.
And the second one is going
to be more of like a reducer.
So once you have collected all the data,
it's going to consolidate
and generate the output.
Let's choose the reducer function here.
So that's pretty much it,
like in terms of what my
distributed map looks like.
Now, one of the other things
that this dataset actually
has is, if you notice, all
of these wind speed data
is provided, you know, the
unit of measure is in knots.
What if, you know, I have a
use case where I don't want it
to be in knots but convert it
into like maybe miles per hour.
So I'm going to use
another Lambda function,
which can help me out to
do that, so convert_mph.
Let's configure that Lambda function.
And pretty much that's it.
Now you may ask or wonder like,
do I need another Lambda function
just to do a convert here?
Not necessary.
You know, the Step Functions
also supports the JSONata.
So you could pretty much use
the math expression to do that.
So you already started
thinking about like, you know,
optimizing this particular workflow.
So it doesn't necessarily have to be
a Lambda function doing this.
That's pretty much it.
And then let's go ahead and create it.
And if you see this screen,
it actually prompts you
with what the Step Functions
of the state mission has
identified as, you know,
based on the workflow it's defined.
It needs the permissions
and the policy set.
So it's actually giving you that visit
that it's going to create all
of these permissions for you.
So let's go ahead and say Confirm.
And it's created the state machine.
It's also, you know, you can also go
and look at the IAM permissions
that it has created.
Now, let's go and execute
this particular workflow.
So in my case, I don't
need to pass an input,
but, you know, it's in case
if your state Step Functions
or the distributed map needs
an input like, you know,
you can pass it in here to test it out.
So I'm just going to click on Start
and wait for the execution.
So now you can see the nice
part about in the console,
where you can see that
it has actually started,
you know, the Map Run state.
So inside the Map Run, you know,
these are some of the observability things
that is made visible to you to see,
like how this state machine is actually
preparing your dataset.
So what you see here is,
in the Pending state,
is the distributed map is actually reading
or iterating over that
list of objects in the S3
and preparing it for the execution.
I also want you to keep an eye
on this particular duration
metrics to see, you know,
how fast it actually takes to
complete this entire execution
of like 600,000 objects.
- [Diego] Yeah, one thing that you can see
is that after we read all of
your contents from your bucket,
we start just batching the executions.
So the difference from the
inline to the distributed map
is that each iteration of your map
becomes a new workflow execution.
And this way, you can parallelize
higher than just being,
having a contention on one execution,
and then you may face limits
with the execution history
and so on, so the distributed
map gives you that option
of each iteration of my
map is its own execution
with its own limits.
And then here you can see that
after it started just
batching the executions,
it's moving over to the Running,
and then the executions
are there on that list.
And we keep track of how many are failing
because if you set tolerant
threshold on failures,
in this case, we'll set it to 5%,
we abort the security,
and then we fail the state.
Also, you can also set a
tolerance threshold on count.
If you don't wanna use percentage,
you can say if 100 failed,
then I just wanna abort.
So one part that it starts getting tricky
is that everything that's
happening here is asynchronous.
And then customers ask
us, "It's very tricky
to understand why some of my iterations
are getting delayed to
happen in the future."
- Cool?
- Yep.
- [Pawan] Yeah, if you see that, you know,
it's taken about two, roughly
two minutes, 15 seconds
to complete all the executions.
And each of these executions, you can see
that it has taken 500 items
at a batch and processed it.
Now, if I go into the S3 bucket
where we have the results,
so you can look at the demo.
And then in this execution,
you have the output CSV file
that it has created.
Now, I can use the, you
know, the visualization tool
like you know, the QuickSight
and show this on the screen.
So this is how, you know, you
can build a Step Functions
distributed map to process,
you know, large-scale data.
- [Diego] Yeah, and if you
were to have any failures,
you would see a separate file here
with the one that says, "Succeeded."
And then that gives you the option
to reprocess just the items that failed
instead of reprocessing the entire thing.
So you can even connect that specific file
to another distributed map
to redrive the ones that failed.
- [Pawan] Before we
move to the next topic,
are there any questions?
We can take maybe a
couple of questions, yeah!
- [Attendee] So here, actually,
you had like set a limit
of 1,000, right, of concurrency limit?
- Yeah.
- In that case,
of all 1,000 Lambdas, which is the limit
actually given on AWS as well,
if it's all exhausted, like
you had done the floor,
like you had like, you
know, other Lambdas,
so will they even get
an opportunity to run
or like will it be processed?
Or what goes on there?
- [Diego] Yeah, so the question
is the default concurrency
was set to 1,000, which
is usually the default
for the Lambda functions.
So if that number was higher,
would the Lambda functions
even have the chance to run?
Okay, so on Step Functions,
when you configure your state
and then as you're doing the
drag and drop in configuration,
there's an option to handle failures.
So you can catch ThrottlingExceptions
and retry with backoff.
And then the workflow
will take care of you
of rerunning them.
I believe there's a few reception types
that you can catch from Lambda,
but if you start more than
what your downstream service
can handle, usually they throttle you,
and then you can catch and
manage on your state machine.
- [Pawan] And just another point
on the Lambda concurrency limit,
that limit is a soft limit to begin with.
Like you can always
open up a support case,
and it'll be, you know,
approved in a few minutes' time.
So it's not a hard limit as such.
- [Attendee] Okay.
- [Pawan] Cool, we'll
move on to the next one.
So Diego, question to you.
So now, we have seen an
example of the Map Run, right?
What sort of like visibility are there
from an observability
standpoint of customers can use
in order to get like, you
know, more deeper insight?
- [Diego] Yeah, usually when
you're investigating things
that are asynchronous, you
don't directly see failures
because they're just
running somewhere out there.
And then after operating
the service for some time,
we noticed that would be great
if we launched new
metrics for our customers,
and we did a few months ago.
So now, you can track the limit
that you have applied on your account
for the amount of open execution
for open Map Runs that runs concurrently.
We also publish how many
you have approximate
running at that specific point of time.
And another one is backlog.
So let's say we're trying
to start more Map Runs,
but because of your limit,
we cannot start more.
So one thing that's great
about Step Functions
is that it doesn't fail.
So even if you're getting throttled,
those things get scared
to happen in the future.
And as soon as something completes,
the other one just takes the limit
and it starts running again.
But one thing that was tricky
is how big is my backlog?
'Cause I don't know how far
or how far are they along
or how longer do I need
to complete all of them?
And we recently launched
those three metrics.
And maybe you can show us
how it looks like on the CloudWatch.
- [Pawan] Yeah, so let me
switch over to the demo.
So while Diego was start talking,
what I did was I have another load-test,
Lambda load test Step Functions here.
So if I just quickly show you,
so what it actually does is
pretty much takes the input
of like from a CSV file,
which has like bunch of random numbers,
and then it goes and
calls this particular,
you know, function, the
another state machine
which simulates the OpenMapRunCount.
So I have a dashboard here.
And if I open, show you the
metrics that we are monitoring,
so these are the metrics
that Diego was mentioning,
which was recently launched.
So you have the OpenMapRunLimit,
which is the maximum,
and then you also have the
current OpenMapRunCount,
which shows you the current status,
and then you have the
MapRunBacklogSize as well.
So now while the load-test
is going on, you know, let's,
if you wait for a few seconds,
we can actually see that, you know,
the Map Run limit is exceeded,
and then you'll start
seeing the run backlog size,
you know, started to increase.
So this, yeah.
- [Diego] Yeah, the important
thing about keeping track
of your backlog is that you
can't even alarm yourself
because maybe you don't even
know that this is happening.
And what could happen as well is someone
sharing the same account
goes and deploys something
that consumes the limits from
that's shared across account,
and then you can identify,
"Oh, this is happening,"
and then we need to
identify what's going on
and what should we stop
or maybe what should we talk to Support
and get higher limits.
And this is where sometimes you can either
just directly talk to Support
or go to Service Quotas
and requesting limit increase,
and then you can quickly
recover from that state.
- [Pawan] So I think we've already
seen like it's actually exceeded.
So if you see the dashboard
over there, the widget,
it's actually already exceeded
the number of OpenMapRunCount,
and then you'll start
seeing the MapRunBacklogSize
started to build up.
So it has a best practice.
Like, you know, this is something
that you should probably
set as a threshold
and then generate an alarm for your team
to like, you know, take an
action or see what's going on.
- [Diego] Right, and keep in
mind that that metric is only
published when there is a backlog.
So if you don't have a
backlog, you'll see no metric,
but eventually, when they happen,
you start seeing the metrics.
And if it's growing, you just see
it keeps going up and up and up.
And then when it starts raining,
you'll see it going down.
And eventually, you'll see
the no-metric data again.
- [Pawan] Okay, probably
we'll take a question
before we move, yeah.
- [Attendee] For distributed map state
that user selected for processing,
if you have like 600,000 files to process
with that single length,
most accounts have like limitation
on asynchronous executions for Lambda,
how does this get around that?
Like would it just run mass invocations
of the Lambda Step Functions
process it matches?
- Do you wanna take that?
- Yeah, so the question is,
in this case, you had
600,000 files from S3,
and then you pass it over to Lambda,
how does Lambda handle that volume
because the limit is one task?
Did I get it right?
- [Attendee] Yeah,
limitation on invocations.
- [Diego] Okay, so what happens here
is that the first thing we
did was to set a batching.
So the payload that you
get on your Lambda function
contains that batching,
then you can manage how
big the batching is.
And then on your Lambda
function, you will handle that.
I believe the number was 500.
- Yeah.
- [Diego] And then as you
run your Lambda function,
the invocations will be
limited to the limits
you have on that specific
function you're calling.
And then similar to the previous question,
if the Lambda throttles you,
you need to catch those errors and retry,
and then you can manage the backoff
for how long you wanna retry.
And then you can even set
the jitter on the state.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Pawan] Yeah, and just
an extension on that point,
like the example that we have
on the Lambda function, right,
actually also calls the S3 APIs as well.
So sometimes if you're
exceeding those limits,
like you know, you can
get throttle exceptions
on the S3 as well.
There's a way to error-handle it
on the Step Functions
itself, like, which is part
of your state machine definition.
And then you could also like
have retry mechanisms as well.
That's all built on the
state machine definition.
Yeah, yeah.
- Thank you.
- [Pawan] Cool, so we've had
a look at the open Map Run.
So now, there's another scenario
that a lot of customers encounter
or like, you know, will
have to keep in mind
is the state transition.
So Diego, what is state
transition in this concept?
And like what sort of behaviors
would you encounter in Step Functions?
- [Diego] Yeah, so state transitions,
you can assume is when
the execution starts,
and when the execution completes,
and when it goes from
one node to the next one.
And when you're talking
about distributed map,
it's each iteration that started.
So Step Functions by default,
it has a limit of 5,000 per
second on state transition.
So let's say you started
a number that's higher than that,
Step Functions gives you 5,000 per second.
And when you try to run more than that
is when you start getting throttled.
Usually when it's an API call,
you get the error immediately back:
429, throttling too many exceptions.
But again, as this is
an asynchronous process
and you may not even see.
Maybe someone went to the account
and started consuming
the state transitions.
This is a shared limit.
So you start getting throttled
and start affecting the
other state machines
running on the same account.
So on the example here, let's
assume you have a bucket.
Every single second, this
bucket gets refilled.
The default limit is
5,000 in large regions.
And then every time there is
a state transition happening,
it consumes one from that bucket.
So let's, in this case, just
to illustrate what's going on,
let's say you started a
huge load on Step Functions.
Eventually, this bucket's gonna be empty,
you're gonna get throttled.
And the good part is that Step Functions
doesn't fail your executions.
Those state transitions get pushed
to happen in the future with a backoff.
So let's say the first
run after one second,
then two, and four, and eight,
and then it keeps increasing,
and there is a limit.
But then for you as an operator,
you go and check your execution,
and it looks like nothing
happened for 30 seconds.
So you may assume, "Oh, there's something
going on with my execution.
Maybe my code is wrong,
maybe my definition,
maybe I'm getting throttled somewhere."
So as an operator, where should you check
to understand if that's the case for you
if you're being affected by this?
So maybe Pawan will build something
that can show that to us?
Maybe have a nice dashboard? (chuckles)
- [Pawan] Cool.
Cool, so I have an example
where you can simulate
the state transition.
So by the way, all the
samples that we're using here,
we'll share it with you in
case if you want to try it
or test it out, so towards the end,
there's a link that we'll
share where you can see,
find all these demos.
So yeah, this is a state machine
that I have which basically
does loops within a loop.
You know, kind of to simulate
the state transition.
So it takes in like the past state
and then has this parallel state
which calls the other choice
state and goes on and on.
Again, going back to my
load-test state machine,
I have just initiated the load-test
on this specific workflow
that I just showed.
Now, if I go back into my dashboard,
there is this metrics that's available
in terms of the State Transition Quota.
So let's just open this to see
what are the things that we're monitoring.
So as Diego mentioned like,
you know, these metrics
is the BucketSize, the RefillRate,
the ConsumedCapacity,
and the ThrottledEvents.
You know, these are all available here.
The best way to like
monitor some of these,
like for example, the BucketSize,
it's the Maximum statistics
that you can use.
Same as the case with the
RefillRate, the Max statistics.
And then you have the ConsumedCapacity,
which can be a sum
aggregation across a minute.
- [Diego] Yeah, one thing to keep in mind
is that CloudWatch metrics,
they're published by minute,
but your limits are per second.
So it's an average across
all the seconds in a minute.
So sometimes you see that you
got throttled in a second,
and then you see the data points,
but then when you look at your limits,
it may not correlate
exactly to the second.
It's just because the metrics
are published every minute.
- [Pawan] Yeah, so if
you see the dashboard,
it's already started showing up
that there are some
throttles that are happening,
the state transitions.
And if you want to find out, you know,
which specific state machine
perhaps was contributing
to this, so let's go ahead
and try and add this execution metrics.
So what I did was selected
ExecutionThrottled as my metrics,
and then I'm going to
choose all my state machines
in my account just to see which one
is actually causing the problem.
And in terms of the
statistics, let's choose Sum
and the Period as one minute.
And let's create it.
So now, it's created a dashboard for me,
oh, sorry, the widget for me.
And in here, I can mouse over,
and then I can see which are
the top two state machines
which are actually
contributed to the throttle.
So one is the state
transition as expected,
which is contributing
to the throttling here.
- [Diego] Yeah, and again, it's important
to understand that your
executions will not fail
because you're getting throttled.
They'll just be running
somewhere in the future.
And then if you encounter this situation,
you can just go to Service
Quotas and request an increase.
And depending on the limit, it
gets automatically approved,
and then things will start moving faster,
and then you'll recover.
- [Pawan] Any questions?
Anybody has any questions?
Maybe we can take couple
of questions, yeah?
- [Attendee] So what's the
configuration which is off?
Even if I got the transactions,
is it all unknown or like
the first limit, what is it?
- [Diego] It's a soft limit.
It's 5,000 per second in large regions.
There's no hard limit.
It's usually given and
provided by use case.
So you can just reach out and say,
"Hey, I have this use case.
I actually need, I don't
know, 30,000 per second."
And then we discuss and decide what.
- [Attendee] Is it per
account or is it per-
- [Congregation] It's per account.
- Per account?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so these-
- It's more just a function
that is much easier.
- [Diego] Sorry?
- [Attendee] So if you
have more of them running,
you can get more?
- Yeah, you consume
more state transitions
across your account.
That's right, yeah.
And having a dashboard that
filters out by state machine
is easier to point it
out which one is the one
that's consuming the most.
Yeah, so on this case,
the limit is different per region.
So large regions, 5,000
and smaller regions is 800.
There are soft limits,
and we can increase.
And with this metric and dashboard,
you can easily identify
why your executions
are being delayed for the case
of state transitions shortly.
But there's also another case
that understanding what's
going on behind the scenes
can simplify the way you
design your state machines.
And in this case is when you
have cross-account integrations.
So let's say you're
building your state machine,
and then you go and invoke
a nested state machine
that belongs to another account.
If the parent and the nested
are in the same account,
Step Functions create something
called managed rules on EventBridge.
And then it listens for the events
on the nested execution completion.
And then automatically
notifies the parent,
completes and move on.
But if you're using cross account,
your state machine cannot read events
from other account by itself.
And the way it works is
by calling the status
of that execution that the parent started.
So let's say you created
a parent with a child,
it's a cross account, the Step Functions
are navigating through your state machine,
it reaches a state that
calls the start executions
on a state machine in another account.
And it's an asynchronous process.
You just get a success
response back saying,
"Hey, I started."
And then it's stuck there, right?
It needs to wait for the
child execution to complete,
and then you're waiting.
Somehow the child completed,
and your parent is still
waiting for the completion.
So what could be the reason
why the parent didn't get notified
from a cross-account invocation?
I'll pass it over to Pawan
that has an example of this happening,
and then we can discuss about this.
- [Pawan] So in terms of the setup
to show you the demo of
this particular scenario.
So we have an account
where you have a workflow
that looks something like this,
where an input, you
know, take, for example,
the product review input,
which has like the product ID,
maybe your description of the product,
and maybe a review of
that particular product.
So it goes through the
workflow of like, you know,
passing through a Bedrock
API, which then analyzes it
to see whether that particular review
was actually a fake
review or a real review.
And then there is a choice state to say,
okay, you know, if it is a fake,
then pass it on to another
logic which will process it.
If it is a real one, then
you would just bypass it.
So that's the workflow that you
have in the Central Account.
Now, then comes maybe
another team that would say,
"Okay, rather than us building this
particular workflow
again in our own account,
why don't we make use of like, you know,
the cross-account invocations?"
Like, you know, from create
a parent workflow here
and then call the child workflow.
So this is what you can,
when you can use a cross
account integrations here.
Typically, what you would
use is the .sync method
or run a job within the Step Functions
naming that you would call
this particular child workflow.
Now, there are few things to keep in mind
while you have this
particular setup, right?
Now, first thing is like each of these
state machine has its own role.
Like in the child
function has its own role
to call Bedrock APIs or maybe other,
you know, AWS services in there,
and your parent function has its own role.
But also, you need to
establish a trust relationship
between, you know, the
cross-account calls.
So what does that look like?
So this is an example of what
that trust policy will look like.
You know, your parent
would need the permissions
to assume role on your child,
the role on your second account,
which is a child account role.
And then on your, the child account,
you need to have a principal
which will make sure
that, you know, it's actually
able to assume the role
with the principal of your parent account.
And then you're also passing
this conditional attribute
into that just to avoid or
not run into the problem call
as a confused deputy, where
it is you're saying that only
allow the assumption
in case if it's coming
from this particular account
or from this particular state machine.
So once you do that, you're
establishing the trust relation.
So this is how the setup looks like.
So that's what I have in my account.
So let me quickly jump to the demo
and show you what it looks like.
So in my parent account,
I have this particular state machine
which is calling my, you know,
the child workflow that
you see cross account.
And while it's also passing, you know,
I'm just also using this target role ARN
for the cross-account invocation.
In my child, I have this
particular nested-process-review workflow.
- [Diego] And while things are loading,
let me explain how it works
behind the scenes on Step Functions.
So we added support for cross
account a few years ago.
And the way Step Function does
it is through role chaining.
So you have an execution
role on your state machine
that is used to run its own steps,
but because we allow cross account,
that execution role
can assume another role
on another account.
And that way, you create
the trust relationship between them.
It's how Pawan created.
So you go to the target role,
which is the one that
is used for chaining.
And then you say, "I
trust that state machine
that's gonna making the call."
And then as the execution
is going through,
it calls some role on that.
And with that credentials,
it makes the API call.
And this is not only for a
Step Functions in nesting,
you can make cross account on
the other services as well,
on the other integrations.
Just make sure you set the target role
because that's what's gonna
be used for role chaining.
And keep in mind that role chaining
is not made by Step Functions.
When the call happens, it's
made by the source account.
So you can have some controls
on the relationship between them.
And it's not Step Functions
making a direct call
because maybe the target
account doesn't even know
that this is coming
through Step Functions.
And probably they shouldn't know
how you architecture your application.
They just receive a call
from a role you trust.
- [Pawan] Cool, so this is what
my child workflow looks like.
Again, the Bedrock API
classifies the review,
and then passes it on.
So let's call the parent workflow here.
So let's go and pass in an input.
So just for fun, let's give it
as the today's date
timestamp just to validate.
And if you see the payload,
it basically has an ID, an overall review,
a reviewText here,
and few other payload information in here.
So let's go ahead and start this.
And you know, this is
called the child workflow.
And you know, you don't
see it yet completed.
This is the problem that
Diego was describing.
And if I actually go
into my child workflow,
you can see that this particular workflow
has received that input
and it has completed that execution.
And if you notice the,
you know, the payload,
let's refresh it once again,
if you see the payload,
this is the ID that we passed in.
And this has completed,
and this has succeeded,
whereas the parent one execution,
it's, you know, if you refresh it,
it is still showing in an execution state.
So something's going on.
- [Diego] Yeah, another
option is to just click
on the execution link that you receive,
yes, if you scroll down.
- Yeah.
- [Diego] There's an execution
link that goes directly
to the child execution that was started.
- [Pawan] Yeah, I think
there's same permissions there.
- [Diego] Yeah, okay, and
because it's cross account.
So in this case, it
can't go to someone else.
- [Attendee] Yeah, I saw it go there.
- Yeah.
- [Diego] Yeah, but if
it's on the same account,
you can just click there and
go to the execution to see,
oh, it's actually completed.
So what's going on with my execution?
It goes back to what I explained before.
When it's in a different
account, you call start,
and that process is
started somewhere else,
but you don't get events
happening from that account.
The way it works is that you
need to poll for the status.
So it's very common that if
you are in the situation,
and you are not very careful
with how you set up the
permissions and relationship,
behind the scenes, Step Functions
is trying to get the
updates for those executions
that happen in somebody else's account,
but is getting access denied.
So in this case, Pawan, how would you
investigate this?
- Yeah,
maybe I'll ask a question to the audience,
and maybe I'll take some
help from the audience.
Like how would you troubleshoot
this kind of a problem?
What tool or what services would you use?
- [Attendee] Ask CloudTrail,
you go check CloudTrail.
- [Pawan] CloudTrail? Okay.
Does anybody agree or deny?
(Diego chuckling)
Okay, let's check CloudTrail.
- Let's go check CloudTrail.
- [Pawan] Yeah, that's a very good option.
Okay, and let's maybe filter it by source
since it's a state.
And let's also filter
in the last 30 minutes.
And yeah.
- Executing.
- [Pawan] So you're right.
So you do see that there
are some AccessDenied
that's already showing up there.
So if I click on this like,
you know, GetExecutionHistory.
- [Diego] It should be
the DescribeExecution.
- [Pawan] Sorry, yeah, the other one.
Yeah, the DescribeExecution.
- [Diego] No, that's the
DescribeStateMachine.
It's probably easier if
you scroll to the right
and see the state
AccessDenied and then yeah.
You can also filter by event
name, DescribeExecution.
- [Pawan] Yeah, let's do that.
- [Diego] And then you
pick the AccessDenied.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
So if you notice this one,
this was related to my execution.
And you can clearly see that, you know,
this particular role, does
it have the permissions
to describe the execution?
So in terms of like fixing this,
let's go ahead and try and fix that.
- [Diego] And in the
meantime, what's going on
on Step Functions is that
for the first 10 minutes,
it pause every minute.
And after, it adds a backoff.
So let's say you're on this
situation, things won't fail.
So as soon as you update your IAM roles,
and permissions, and relationship,
if something is wrong,
eventually they'll just
recover and succeed.
- [Attendee] Does it poll
only if it's cross account
or does it also poll
if you do an execution
in the same account?
- [Diego] It also polls
if it's the same account,
but because it's the same account,
events from EventBridge is just faster.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, so it rarely
completes through the poll,
but as when they always said-
- Minimum waiting as well.
- [Diego] Yeah, that's
when they always say,
"Thing fails all the time."
So if the event, for some
reason, is not delivered,
some reason, it's lost on the network,
the poll is your backup.
- [Attendee] So it's event
driven with a backup call.
- [Diego] Yeah, exactly.
It's a way to make it more reliable
because we don't want to fail
if the child succeeded.
So the way we do is to
poll just for guarantees.
(attendee speaking indistinctly)
So the parent wait...
So the question was, it
doesn't fail the execution,
it keeps polling?
- [Attendee] Yeah, because
then actually succeeded.
The execution has some,
you know, latest status.
- [Diego] Yeah, that's right.
So the parent is still
waiting for the completion
of the child execution,
but the child completed a few minutes ago.
- [Attendee] Yeah, so
when you say backoff,
it's just like what, within
the status, it keeps polling?
- [Diego] Yes, exactly,
because it needs to know what happened.
So if you don't have permission
to check somebody else's account,
you can access that information.
And the way it works
is by the role chaining
as it needs the
DescribedExecution permission
so it can get what happened,
and then complete your
own state and move on.
- [Attendee] And you'll get a timeout
obviously behind the poll, exactly.
Possibly failing at some
point in time, but if you-
- [Attendee] But you gotta
put, you'd put a timeout?
- [Diego] Yeah, one option
is to put the timeout, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Will backoff done though?
- [Diego] But then it's
gonna fail eventually
and move on, right?
Yeah.
- [Pawan] So if you see
the role permissions
on this particular child role,
right now, it only has a StartExecution.
So what we need to do is we
add the DescribeExecution
as well as the StopExecution.
So let's go ahead and
add those permissions in.
- [Diego] Another one
that's important for nesting
in cross account is the
StopExecution as well
if you want the parent to
stop the child execution
if the parent fails.
So what happens is you
have your parents running,
it starts a child, the
child is just running,
and let's say you wanna abort the parent.
So what Step Function
does is a best effort
to stop the execution as well.
But if it doesn't have permission
to stop the execution of the
child, the child execution,
then it just moves on.
So then you can see the AccessDenied
on CloudTrail as well if that's the case.
- [Attendee] So will people exactly ask
for the specifics of function run
because you're using
the Describe permission.
You don't need the List.
- [Diego] Yeah, you don't need the List.
It's only the Describe
because you need to know
what the output is.
- [Attendee] Calling child role.
- [Diego] Yeah, that's right.
- DescribeExecution only?
- Yeah, the question was,
you don't need the List permission,
just the Describe, yeah.
And the Describe is the one
that provides your input,
and output, and the state.
(attendee coughing)
- [Pawan] All right, let's
add the stop_describe_policy.
So that's in here on
that specific execution
related to my demo nested workflow.
And let's go ahead and
give it another try now.
Okay, let's copy.
Let's give the overall as four,
and then start the execution.
- [Attendee] So you know that,
so this is only a poll method.
So there is no push from
apart from the (indistinct).
- [Diego] Yeah, the question
is for cross account,
it's only polling.
Yeah, that's right.
If it's the same account,
then the events get notified
through the managed rule
that's created on EventBridge.
And EventBridge sends those
events to Step Functions,
and Step Functions identifies the event,
and then, oh, this is for
that execution that's waiting,
and then completes that task and move on.
- [Attendee] It's interesting
that you have, yeah,
the previous ones are now succeeding
like the first one, yeah.
- Exactly, yeah.
Exactly, yeah.
- [Diego] So that's
because on the next run,
because we back off on the next run,
we try to get new credentials to poll.
And then we call the DescribeExecution.
This time, it succeeded.
So we can complete the
parents that were waiting,
and then it just moves on.
- [Pawan] So yeah, all the
previous running states
have all completed now.
- [Attendee] So who do
we talk to to make him
poll a little bit faster for the future?
One minute for the first
poll is kind of high.
- [Diego] Yeah, you can
always reach out to us,
and we can customize.
- [Attendee] You know,
10 seconds, then back up.
You know, it then do again
or something like that.
- [Diego] Yeah, but usually
when those things run too fast,
let's say you started tens
of thousands of executions,
if they're all trying to
poll, you may get throttled.
So those things have to follow also
a limit increase for the pollers.
And yeah, this is what we discussed.
The resolution on this case
is because the parent workflow
is trying to poll for the status
to understand what's going
on with the child execution.
And this is because it's a cross account,
it cannot read events from somebody else
for security reasons.
And what Step Function does
is, hey, I need permissions
to read information
from the other account.
And by doing the role chaining,
I'm going to assume a role
using your credentials for that account.
And with the credentials
from the chaining,
I'm gonna call the DescribeExecution API.
And after we fixed and
updated the permissions
on the next run, on the next check,
it will just succeed, it'll complete,
and then it will just move on.
So here on these permissions, you can see
the required for nesting
is Describe and Stop.
And the Stop is if you
want child executions
to be terminated when the
parent execution is aborted
or fails, let's say the
parent execution time is up,
you don't want the child
execution to keep running.
Maybe there is a use case that you want
to keep them running and succeed.
But in case if you don't,
you can just add the permission to stop,
and Step Functions is
going to make a best effort
to stop them.
On the event part is
because there is a feature
from EventBridge called managed rules.
And the Step Functions
create a managed rule
to read events from your account.
And then those events get delivered,
and Step Functions know exactly how
to write them, route them,
and complete the parent executions
and with specific task that's waiting.
And if you don't have those permissions
that create state machine
with a .sync integration,
it's going to fail
because we can't create the
managed rule on your behalf.
- [Attendee] Does it support
like waitForTaskToken?
'Cause that might be a way that
you could not have to poll.
- [Diego] Yeah, the question is,
does it support waitForTaskToken?
It does, so you can control yourself.
You can get a token and get it delivered,
and then somewhere else-
- [Attendee] Yeah, the final
state of now execution can-
- [Diego] Can call it back.
- You can do that, yeah.
- If can, didn't wanna wait.
- [Diego] Yeah, that's right.
But sometimes you can't modify the child,
so you can't add this extra step.
But if you can, this is a
faster way of completing.
We just need to make sure you
have the right permissions
because it will be a cross account.
So you need to assume
a role on that account
and call this SendTaskSuccess in this case
or SendTaskFailure if it failed,
but then it's not a managed integration
cross account anymore.
And yeah, you have to do it.
Any other questions on this?
Okay.
- [Pawan] Cool, so yeah, just
to conclude all the demos
that we have done in this session,
you can find it on that GitHub link.
So you can scan this QR code.
It'll take you straight
into that GitHub page.
Yeah, and you can try it
out in your own account
and test it out.
There's also a link to
the Compute blog post.
So this is where we
would publish, you know,
anything about Step Functions,
the new releases, launches,
some of the best practices,
how do you do things at scale,
and things like that, so all
of those will be published
under the Compute blog.
- [Diego] Yep, and for example,
if you want to run even faster,
you can just either
increase the batch size
or give it more concurrency.
Just be aware that if you get throttled,
things may get delayed,
and then you need to
request a limit increase.
But those metrics that
we launched recently
for distributed map, they
do help on these cases
that you can just see what's going on
and see, "Oh, I really
have a backlog here.
I need to handle that."